[Music]
this is what we like to see you and
we're settling in for a movie over two
minutes of black screen opening credits
slow burning light bulb serves as an
analogy for the slow burning realization
your brain has during this movie which
sadly will be five minutes behind the
film's actual review olivia williams
isn't my girlfriend or still-living wife
in the scene
apparently there's already a ghost
wandering around this house that makes
an achiever and that is never solved and
that person apparently never goes to see
Haley Joel Osment either remember
Malcolm isn't dead yet so who's the
mystery ghost making it Cole and don't
tell me it's the guy upstairs because he
isn't dead yet either
yep fire and paper go hand-in-hand
excellent mantel decoration choices here
recognition of his outstanding
achievement in the field of child
psychology exposition via awarded plaque
the countless children and their family
Jesus you're going to read the whole
thing marry people even when you're a
disturbed former patient of a renowned
psychologist you enjoy running from one
place to the next in the background to
scare people huh unexpected discount
Donnie what the this is 47 Locust Street
why does Malcolm tell the obvious
possibly crazy intruder who isn't lost
what the address is movie will now
proceed to the next fall because as we
all know even though he got shot there
was no way Bruce Willis's character is
dead I am 100% certain of this so that
unimportant shooting requires no further
storytelling because he survived and one
day he and his wife will look back on
this night and laughed also while this
restricts the time jump to inside 365
days it really does nothing to tell us
how much time is passed did the shooting
take place late September for example or
in February
director obsessed with one specific
location is obsessed psychiatry stalking
petty theft the second paragraph of this
notebook discusses a conversation in the
church that Malcolm and Cole did not
have that wasn't even as much as a star
white that suggests what we saw in the
church wasn't the whole conversation
Malcolm sand is amazing at building
dramatic tension so the ghosts walked in
open all the drawers and cabinets then
left how are you supposed to get what
you want doing that also that was the
quietest opening of drawers and cabinets
at that speed in the history of things
being open hastily also Cole's mom does
not question the fact that she turned
away from the kitchen for what amounts
to 10 seconds and that this is
impossible for her kid to do in the time
allotted
yes and try not to peek down my shirt
when I tell you this mom advice there's
no way you're seeing that from this
distance freak how'd you like that arm
around the shoulder bit this kid fails
to be eaten by Raptors in two years you
know you watch this movie once and
you're like whoa
you went to the second time and you're
like damn but if you watch it a third
time or more you end up mostly thinking
well also Jesus I didn't realize how
many whammy moments em Knight totally
staged in this movie regardless of all
logic okay this step forward or backward
scene is fantastic because it's shot
well and provides a unique way to learn
expositional information while seeing
character development play out once and
remove from one of the reasons we all
originally loved him Knight sure I guess
Cole doesn't care if his mom hears him
or just happens to walk past the living
room while he plays this game with an
invisible person I think you know I
don't know what you're thinking now hey
that's not the rule of the game he's not
wrong he's being honest although you're
nice
you can't help isn't it exactly what
Malcolm told him II was thinking at the
very beginning of this game that Cole
didn't think Malcolm could help him
happy anniversary seen only inserted
into this movie in order to trick you
that's bullshit swearing in front of
children this is the first time she's
ever noticed this super obvious ghost
lens flare also ghost lens layer and
it's on all of the pictures least
observant mother ever Cole's mom is
addicted dogs so cools writing normal
journal stuff then suddenly someone
starts writing crazy all over it now
maybe a ghost did that maybe Cole is
writing what the ghost says maybe Cole's
possessed but then after all the crazy
talk Cole continues writing like nothing
happened in fact he wrote because I
before the crazy part and then rude
again after the crazy part like nothing
happened so what the cat in there
because it seemed kind of down lately
is it your dead husband it's probably
your dead husband I mean it's amazing
how many conversations about himself
Malcolm over here is where no one
mentioned them by name guy who's in love
with Anna turns toward the house and
practically looks like a stalker so that
we'll all know he's a guy who's in love
with Anna keep moving cheese dick cheese
dick Easter hang people here kid who is
extremely self-aware and knows not to
draw violent pictures anymore and wants
to keep this seeing dead people thing a
secret decides yeah this is the kind of
answer my teacher wants
fired looks like an ordinary penny since
we know Malcolm is actually dead this
whole time how does this penny work if
someone were to walk in with a CF
loading penny
or is it also dead Anna apparently
started watching this wedding video then
left it on while she took a shower so
that Malcolm could walk in and enjoy it
not to mention the audience over the
entire year Malcolm's been dead has
there ever been a time where he sat down
on the couch and Anna came in and sat
down on the exact spot where he was
sitting I don't know how you justify
that you're hit but surely it's happened
once or twice I know he's a little kid
but damn you're at a stranger's house
and you saw him balloon in addition to
being a scared scarred boy who sees dead
people you're just gonna go wandering
willy-nilly around this house oh these
assholes come from wasn't cool at the
base of the stairs when the scene
started LL Cool looks like he's in a
completely different part of the house
than these two are when they start
climbing the stairs and I don't see
coals I'm a lonely boy at a birthday
party paper plate and matching pillow
anywhere either he did we know that Cole
is unpopular to say least and the scene
illustrates early on that Cole's mom
doesn't fit in with this kid's wealthy
parents so how did this dad even know or
care to invite Cole
there was no way these parents heard
cold screams from down here with kids
yelling and loud music play this is the
movie where M night Shyamalan decided it
would be a good idea to put M night
Shyamalan in his movies there's some
cuts and bruises from your son
concerning me you know we existed back
in 1999 this insert of Bruce Willis
saying oh man
like the disconnected dead dude he is
would have set off all the alarms why
doesn't the mama harass Malcolm what's
going on with her kid is he dead his
family doesn't look like they can afford
a child psychologist so yeah he's
probably dead but back in 1999 we were
like when are we gonna get to the I see
dead people part we have to add splits
and stuff like what kind of twists
Commun example baby they ran out of gas
maybe you find out Malcolm's been dead
this whole time we have to it's twisted
stuff also after writing this line of
dialogue em night was so impressed with
it
he had a cross digit unframed and it
still hangs above his mantle to this day
maybe they ran out of gas that's not a
twist that's a horror cliche
virtually no way this movie would get
made today it takes 50 minutes for Cole
to share his secret and we haven't even
seen any real ghost stuff yet the movie
is pretty damn compelling to keep your
attention to the halfway point without a
whole lot happening so we'll take us in
off suffering from visual hallucinations
look I know Malcolm is dead but why
would he pick the streets of
Philadelphia to record his thoughts on
coal this seems like a breach of
confidentiality even though he's dead
but he doesn't know that hi this is Lynn
sear Cole's mom wait a minute this
family's name is the Sears
like Sears like sees dead people whether
or not he knows it and night inspired
the entire Paranormal Activity franchise
with this sequence of shots is this not
the exact same ghost that's been opening
all the cabinets and drawers before how
does cool mistake this obvious goes for
his mom and Cole really has a lot of
contraband in this tent piracy yeah but
isn't cool used to this by now he even
mentioned the hanging people when
stuttering Stanley told him he was a
freak earlier so why is this a big deal
anymore
for him and the audience is finally
seeing this stuff for the first time but
he isn't thank you it's called
movie uses both made-up reason to
explain why Cole's breath isn't visible
during scenes with Malcolm and this
movie uses a lot of feed to Black's Cole
throws a goddamn shoe at the television
it only gets a playful chiding we're not
being praying I must not be praying
right this is certainly the problem
[Music]
keep Scott why are all the other ghosts
in this movie introducing themselves in
this creepy manner in the very situation
they were in when they died
Malcolm showed up - Cole is a child
psychologist and is in no way reliving
the moments of his death in front of him
[Music]
did Malcolm watch them from outside the
store somehow and smash the window or
did he see Anna and the stalker about
the kiss run out smash the window and
leave because from Malcolm's perspective
wouldn't he be wondering why his wife is
kissing another man right in front of
him and if he's outside the store how
did he see it in the first place did you
understand
Malcolm breaks up with Cole because his
wife almost kissed a guy because it's
impossible to treat one boy and be a
good husband apparently so Malcolm
finally learns the truth about the kid
who turned into Donnie Wahlberg but it's
actually kind of amazing that this
award-winning psychologist didn't
remember to check his tapes after this
session where Vincent was fine when he
left him and not fine when he came back
do you think these ghosts want when they
talk to you does Cole know that Malcolm
is dead I guess he does but since he
never does anything these other ghosts
do it makes me wonder if he really knows
and and he never once lets on even after
Malcolm accepts the fact that Cole can
see dead people
one man hailey Joe Osmond is so good in
this movie I take a sin off if I hadn't
seen pay it forward the following year
what they're just saying they just wanna
hurt somebody I don't think that's the
way it works oh well okay if you have a
feeling that by all means
mom has helpful sleep-talking nightmare
to help the son understand how much she
loves it okay so the clothes pins are
unsnapping from his tent and ah prio see
Mischa Barton and I'm wondering how she
fit through the slit in the tent and
went unnoticed by Cole who can see dead
people
also luckily for Cole he was just told
that he needed to ask what the dead
people wanted and this girl just happens
to have an easy mystery to solve that
will immediately take her to the
afterlife go spooky
although I will say this is still Mischa
Barton best work today my question is
why does your mom just let you go on
scooby-doo adventures by yourself and
fill a freaking delvia uninvited wait
guests can just storm into the week with
no questions because morning I guess I
mean I've been sad at every week I've
ever attended emotional even but I would
definitely notice absolute strangers who
shouldn't know my dead daughter damn it
Jesus don't they have an arrangement why
is this little girl being a ghost dick
right now damn dude didn't you just see
this chick last night her mouth was full
of vomit then this is not nearly as
scary as that was for you what it
ask no questions about how I nine year
old know about this nothing to see here
Kiera decided to be kind and rewind it
holy he decided to watch this home movie
some strange boy said was from his dead
daughter in front of all the wait guests
luckily for this mystery ultimate answer
this mom totally doesn't see what is
probably a bulky 1999 VHS camcorder with
a blinking red light that manages to
perfectly capture her mom pouring pine
cleaner into her suit who turned off the
camera Jesus another fade to black now
I'm wide awake why didn't we see the
signs and this guy's unbreakable movie
recipe way back when they were happening
who who were you talking to yeah so he
was able to help her out by solving her
murder so how the hell can he help
anybody else who doesn't have a murder
she wrote episode in their lives does he
give them therapy a pat on the back a
hug I got an idea how you can talk to
your wife wait till she's asleep then
she listen you and she won't even know
it you've been helping ghosts all of
like three days or something now that do
you know that will work in fact I know
it won't work but whatever let's get on
to the surprise twist Andy why is the
traffic on the other side of the road
stop too the wreck happened in the left
lane and many of these cars are past the
wreck but for some reason the road is
entirely blocked going in the other
direction communicate with you
what are opening lines that don't work
well with the ladies at the local
singles bar for 200 Alex died where she
stands next to my window Kolak specs his
mom to believe this without any kind of
proof and Dan player for the dramatic
much yeah he's probably busy he'll be
able to help me out later somehow by
telling me how he really wishes people
would watch out for cyclists more when
they're driving knowing whose hopes and
wishes even though nothing will ever be
done about it well let me die in peace
she wanted me to tell you she wanted me
to tell you she saw you dance damn dude
couldn't you have led with this I know
you're a kid but damn that was a lot of
bull preamble to get to the part where
you proved you can talk to dead people
he's see you've ticked and amazingly
held on to this story for years and
years before she died
just in case her grandson needed that
brew he could talk to dead people also
Cole keeps this mother of all definitive
proof stories regarding ghosts and his
grandmother in his back pocket the
entire movie because reasons you've kept
it to place every day Grammy didn't tell
me the question so that it would be more
dramatic when you told me what the
question was it's like ghost jeopardy
yeah
wow this exactly gonna work I suppose
you could argue ghosts Malcolm has done
his part and is ready to accept the
truth but if ghosts only see what they
want to see why is he suddenly seeing
this also a good thing she's holding on
to that wedding ring and dropped it
right now or else this talking to her
while she's asleep thing definitely
wouldn't work but what a reveal it is
right it wasn't anything that hadn't
been done before but the way it's done
is great still gives me chills to this
day how good it is in fact it's a five
sin removal worthy reveal just by the
way Anna decided to stay in the house
where her husband was murdered and where
the other dude committed suicide seems
like that would be reason enough to move
out but she decided to constantly remind
herself of this horrible tragedy every
time she goes to take a shower why he
blows out cold breath even though the
movie clearly stated it gets cold
only when ghosts get upset and angry
even though the emotion goes Malcolm is
feeling right now is relieved her
acceptance
do you know why you're afraid when
you're alone I do you do
[Music]
your dad gave you that watch as a
present just before he went away
it's watch it's on your daddy's wrist
they were shut down I know I just found
a picture hi I wanna heal it was an only
note and lately she's in love with a
dead guy anyway I do my little magic
shakin Maria but you wouldn't clap yet
because making something disappear isn't
enough you have to bring it back that's
a big thing got me Tommy Tommy Tommy
Tommy Cole who throws a shoe honestly
you see most most blogs gonna be playing
at 10:00 you're on 10 here all the way
up all the way up you know the way up
you're on 10 on your guitar
where can you go from there well I don't
know where exactly yo sup y'all know
there's a rage hell high ridge I could
not tell I want to tell you I love you I
love you too daddy
I'll be right here when you get back